[MUSIC PLAYING]
Marvel Studios' She-Hulk
Attorney at Law has some
smashing visual
effects, which is why
I'm speaking with VFX
supervisor Shannon
Justison and Dadi Einarsson.
Hey folks.
All right, let's jump in.
Now there are some unbelievable
visual effects in the series.
But what's the most
interesting thing
about working on the series?
I think the most interesting
thing for doing the VFX
for a show like this is
that we have a CG lead
and that has never been
done on a Marvel television
show before because
it's a little crazy.
I mean it's a huge show.
There are digital
humans involved.
So you're creating something
using a lot of input data
and a lot of
performance capture.
But ultimately
it's a CG creation
that's going to be acting
alongside actual human actors.
It was all about making sure
that we had everything in place
to get the best
performance recorded,
so that we could deliver on
a she-hulk character that
represented Tatiana's
acting ability.
Still in control No the
overwhelming feelings of rage?
No.
A normal amount of rage.
So you know walking into that
room you were going to have
a fully CG lead character.
Where do you start?
So if you're going to create
a fully digital character like
She-Hulk, there's sort of
two streams you're pursuing
at the same time.
The first is Visdev,
which would be standard
for any sort of CG character.
We have a visual development
department here at Marvel.
They look at all the comic
books and they look at how
our story is telling her story.
And then the other side of that
is that we look at our casting.
The important part
of this is that we
need to know what
Tatiana looks like
in order to be able to transform
her in and out of She-Hulk.
We in VFX subject her to a lot
of scanning and photography.
That then goes to
build stage and that
goes through multiple
steps of development,
making the model look as
real as possible, just
in terms of like a
physical proportions
and the physical aspect of it.
So once you've done
all of that digital work
you have Tatiana
Maslany performance.
How do you pair the CG and
her performance together?
We captured petabytes of data.
It was absurd how much
data we pulled off the set.
We actually had a really
big on set VFX team
just because we had so much
data acquisition to do.
When we're recording
mocap and H.M.C., on set,
we've got several sets
of data that we're
actually kind of picking out.
So the mocap data
actually records not video
but it is straight data.
And that is purely data that's
recorded to a digital skeleton,
so if you had walked over
to the mocap brain bar
while we were recording, you
could see a little skeleton
running around doing Tatiana's
or Mark's performances,
which is pretty wild.
Once you have all of
that data and footage,
how do you bring them
together into a scene
to create a realistic
She-Hulk performance?
In order to make
She-Hulk more lifelike,
we always start with
the animation first,
because for a
character like this,
that's the foundation of
everything that is to follow.
I mean, there
are so many things
that we consider when
we're trying to make
her feel as real as possible.
We try to make it as close to
what Tatiana did as possible,
and really see what
the essence of each one
of those performances is.
So starting from
the edit, then we
can start working from selects.
Based on the selects,
we would for instance
we say we have a She-Hulk shot.
This is the shot that
the editors have chosen.
This is the mocap performance.
All that goes over
to a vendor and then
they start their process
of tracking the plates,
ingesting the mocap, which
means transferring the mocap
data to the She-Hulk rig.
And yeah, the thing
that's most exciting
is just seeing it come together.
Seeing it come to life.
It's a long process.
We would start by post vising,
and where Tatiana would
be walking around
in her mocap suit,
we would then put in a She-Hulk
in kind of a low Res quick turn
around post this form so that
could start to inform our edit.
While the animation
team is working away,
the shaders team is
working on refining
all of the look of her
skin texture, her hair
texture, her clothing texture.
We're building out her clothes.
We're building out her shoes.
Then really once you
get turnover and start
to build that scene and see
the things coming to life,
you start to match the lighting.
You start to see the performance
go on the actual She-Hulk
animation puppet.
It's super exciting seeing that
character come to life once.
Once have an animated
performance that we like
and the studio buys
off on, at that point
we start all of what we call
the Sims, the simulations.
That's where we start the
clothing simulations, the hair
simulations, and
because all of that
is driven by the
animation, we don't
really start that until after
the animation is complete.
She-Hulk has so
many different looks.
I imagine that's a lot of work.
How typical is it
for a CG character
to have that many outfits?
Yeah so She-Hulk
has 25 outfits,
which is crazy amount
of different outfits,
like usually CG characters
will have one, maybe two.
She has to be in court.
She has to be casual.
She has to be kind
of working out.
But you still get
to have a lot of fun
with like how do the
clothes transform?
What happens to her shoes?
DADI EINARSSON: Each
one of these outfits
has to be digitally created.
It has to have its simulation.
There'll be multiple
layers to it.
In one of our episodes,
She-Hulk turns up
at a Gala event for
female lawyer of the year,
and she is wearing
a sequenced dress.
She-Hulk's Gala
dress the sequin dress.
It's incredibly complicated
and terrifying to build in CG.
DADI EINARSSON: The
dress is mind blowing.
It is so amazingly well done.
I think there are over a
million sequins that sparkle.
They catch the light correctly.
They have to be
form fitting on her.
They have to flow with the
dress and I'm just constantly
aware of when I'm
reviewing those shots
just how like what
an achievement it
was to make that dress.
Oh my God.
That thing is incredible.
It's so well done.
It really is so incredible,
and the whole series
really is so special.
What are you most
proud of looking
back at this entire series?
I'm really excited for
people to see this character.
I'm excited for kids,
my kids to see her.
And yeah, just being involved
with of bringing to the screen
so many shots of
a digital human.
I am very grateful for
the opportunity to be
involved with something so big.
I really feel like
it's been an honor
to be part of the she-hulk team,
especially as the VFX team.
I love origin stories and
she's such a fun and like witty
and she's meta.
And she's just such
a great character.
So to be a part of her origin
story is just a privilege.
Oh, Shannon and Dadi, it was
such a blast getting to talk
with you a bit
more about She-Hulk
and how you bring her to life.
Thank you so much.
And of course everyone make
sure you go watch all episodes
of Marvel Studios'
She-Hulk: Attorney at Law
now streaming only
on Disney Plus.